the venom sequel unleashes a lot of
carnage but it doesn't have answers for
everything you want to know will ann
ever dump doctor down and get with a
hero instead of a zero well venom
finally meets spider-man these are the
biggest unanswered questions and venom
let there be carnage
in a key scene of the venom sequel eddie
brock goes to visit cletus cassidy in
san quentin at first trying to play
things cool eddie finally loses it when
the convicted serial killer begins
comparing himself to eddie cassidy
killed multiple members of his family
eddie he claims killed a family member
when he was born in the comics eddie's
mother did indeed die from complications
during childbirth a tragedy compounded
when his father carl brock came to treat
the child with an icy angry detachment
much of what eddie became athlete star
student journalists was in a desperate
attempt to gain his father's approval
and warmth in actuality brock is
somewhat in the neighborhood of cletus
cassidy while that first death may not
have been his doing an older brock got
drunk in the comics once and
accidentally struck and killed a child
with his father's car in that storyline
eddie wanted to turn himself in and face
some music but his dad talked him out of
it whichever eddie brock storylines are
making their way to the silver screen
this much is certain eddie has some
serious guilt on his shoulders cassidy
knows exactly which buttons to push and
when eddie gets mad venom wants to help
his buddy out but ultimately this fit of
rage only leads to cassidy taking in the
symbiote causing more death and
destruction
is venom gay those are three words you
most likely didn't think you'd be asking
yourself on the way out of the theater
but it's a very real question that the
movie definitely brings up venom let
there be carnage has a scene where the
symbiote on the rebound after a bad
breakup with eddie finds himself at a
san francisco wraith after turning down
the advances of a woman the alien gets
up on stage and delivers a rant that
includes the declaration i am out of the
eddie closet speaking about the movies
credited writers kelly marcel and tom
hardy circus implied that the scene very
much means what you think it means he
shared in an interview with uproxx tom
and kelly were always about venom coming
out and going to a party that was a very
sort of an lgbtqia kind of festival
really i'd call it so this is his coming
out party basically this is venom's
coming out party we already know that
venom has a certain degree of gender
fluidity the symbiote inhabits genders
indiscriminately and although venom has
come to appreciate eddie brock even at
one point declaring love for him venom
also seems to enjoy inhabiting old mrs
chen's body and having anne get flirty
the bottom line by the end of the film
venom seems happy and comfortable with
himself that's all that matters you bent
your ass
venom let there be carnage doesn't give
viewers any idea where shriek aka
francis barrison got her powers
specifically we're talking about her
ability to emit an eardrum piercing
scream that can kill humans and
temporarily disorient sound sensitive
symbiotes like venom and carnage instead
the audience meets francis in a style at
saint hester's reform school adjacent to
cletus cassidy who makes her a paper
promise ring before she is whisked off
to a new home at ravencraft mental
institution much of this is because in a
series where everyone else seems to be
gaining powers via symbiotes shriek's
talents are derived from her status as
what has been a dirty word for movies
based on marvel comics not called x-men
mutant back around the turn of the
century as marvel sold rights to various
properties to studios only 20th century
fox secured the rights to the mutant
corner of the marvel universe which it
famously used for its own series of
x-men movies now things appear to be on
the path to mutants finally joining the
mcu but since the venom films are
technically sony productions in sony's
own universe of marvel characters you
can see where things get muddled in the
original marvel comics trick had a
horrific upbringing that involved
physical abuse body shaming drug use and
even being shot in the head by a police
officer all this led to the awakening of
her later mutant abilities which
includes sound manipulation levitation
and even some psychic powers and mind
control based on the explosive end
credits of this venom movie it's not
likely we'll get answers about shriek's
mutant origins anytime soon
the first time venom sees carnage in the
flesh the black symbiote recedes back
into eddie brock's body like he's a
frightened hulk who just saw thanos walk
into the club oh [ __ ]
as comic fans know many symbiote species
have their own colours with venom being
black scream coloured yellow sleeper
being green and so on the reason why
carnage has red is because it entered
cletus through his bloodstream in the
comics eddie was in a prison cell with
cletus when venom spawn accessed
custardy through a cut in his hand in
the movie a somewhat similar event
occurs even if it gets tweaked a bit
although brock and cassidy onto nacelle
together the serial killer manages to
bite into eddie after which he remarks
upon the unique composition of eddie's
inner workings i have tasted blood
before and that is not it whatever it is
it is compounded when the state tries to
put cletus cassidy to death via lethal
injection carnage uses the opportunity
to finally seize cassidy breaking free
from the restraints and beginning his
killing spree so why is venom so afraid
of a red one well for starters anyone
can see that carnage is clearly bigger
and seems to have more weapons at the
ready it's also generally accepted that
each spawn of a symbiote is stronger
than the one before it so venom knows
right off the bat that he's at a
disadvantage also it never helps when
the symbiotes are about to go up against
has chosen a host who just so happens to
be a ruthless serial killer but the
significance of him being red and not
being scarier that's unexplained who
knows maybe venom just read the comic
books when he was a kid and knows with
one glance that he's in for maximum
carnage
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite movies and tv shows are
coming soon subscribe to our youtube
channel and hit the bell so you don't
miss a single one
[Music]